ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าชาร์ปวันนี้
วันอะไรคะวันนี้วัน
พฤหัสบดีวันนี้วันพฤหัส
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 21
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนเมษายน
ปีพตอะไรคะ
ปีคศอะไรคะ
ต่อ
2022 ค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะครูฟ้า
เมื่อวานนี้วันอังคารวันพุธ
ฝัน Wood หนาวันพุธวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
วันที่ 20 เดือน
เมษายน
ปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ
2  022 ค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วัน
ศุกร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
22 เดือนเมษายน
ปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ
2  022 ค่ะค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้
เวลา 12:00 น
เที่ยงกี่นาทีคะครูฟ้า
25 นาทีค่ะกระเทียม 25 นาทีก็เป็นจับ
เวลาตรางวัลเป็นตอนกลางวันนะคะวันนี้หรือ
ว่าวีดีโอนี้นะคะครูหญิงเนี่ยมีคำถามมา
ถามครูฟ้าอีกแล้วค่ะ
ไม่รู้ว่าครูฟ้าชอบชอบตอบคำถามไว้นะ
ทำผู้หญิงชอบถามออกเป็นคำถามที่
มันอ่ะเราจะบอกว่าครูหญิงเนี่ยถามครูฟ้า
แต่ว่าให้ครูฟ้าเนี่ยคิดใช่ไหมว่าถ้าคำ
ถามคนอื่นๆถ้า
จุดครูฟ้าจะทำอะไรมาเป็นคำถามที่เราบอก
ว่าไม่จริงใจไม่จริงไม่ใช่เรื่องจริงผู้
หญิงแค่คิดถ้า
คุณครูฟ้าไม่ได้ไม่ใช่คนไทยๆถ้าครูฟ้าไม่
ใช่คนไทยครูฟ้าคิดว่าจะเป็นคนประเทศอะไร
ถ้ากรูฟ้าไม่ใช่คนไทย
จะเป็นคนประเทศอะไร
[เพลง]
ถ้าครูฟ้าไม่ใช่เป็นคนเพื่ออะไรถ้าครูบา
ไม่ใช่คนไทยนะฮะป่าก็อาจจะเป็น
อะไรเนี่ย
ตีนมั้งคนซิถ้ากูบ้าไม่ใช่คนไทยครูฟ้าจะ
เป็นคนจีนซึ่งพอเป็นคนไทยจีน
นี่ไงถึงไว้มันเป็นคำถามที่เราบอกว่าเรา
คิดขึ้นมาแต่ไม่จริงสวยไม่จริงเพราะจริงๆ
ครูฟ้าเป็นคนไทยนะเป็นคนไทยและก็เป็น
ครึ่งถามสนุกๆนะคะสนุกๆค่ะข้อที่ 1
dx3 โปรให้สั่งโปรมาข้อที่ 1 ครูฟ้ากับ
ครูหญิงแหละเป็นคนนะคะเป็นคนเนาะ
แต่ว่าคนสวยเป็นคนไทยนักเรียนอาจจะเป็นคน
จีนคนเกาหลีคนอเมริกาคนอังกฤษคนฝรั่งเศส
สวยเป็นคนและถ้าครูฟ้าเป็นสัตว์นะเป็น
สัตว์ได้ 1 ตัวแล้วเป็นสัตว์จะเป็นเสือ
เป็นสิงห์โต
เป็นลาค่ะเป็นปูนะคะเป็นสัตว์เนาะถ้าครู
ฟ้าเป็นสัตว์ได้ 1 ตัวครูฟ้าจะเป็นตัว
อะไรอ่ะ
อุ้ยหมีค่ะ
ครูฟ้าจะเป็นหมีหรอผู้หญิงหาหมีก่อนได้
มั้ย
หมีขาวหมีของเทพ
ผู้หญิงมี
ผู้หญิงเนี่ย
วินสีขาวนะคะหรือว่าหมีขั้วโลกที่อยู่อัด
ติกใช่มั้ยอ้ะอ๋อครูบาจะเป็นหมีพูห์พา
ร้อนนะมันจะเป็นสีขาวแล้วก็จะได้บาย
Thailand ก็จะไปแอนตาร์กติกาไปอัพฟิต
ขึ้นนี่แหละหนา 80 กระทั่งนานามุกอ๋อคุณ
ฟ้าจะเป็นหมีขาวใช่ไหมถ้ากูฟ้าจะเป็น
สัตว์ได้ 1 ตัวกูว่าจะเป็นหมีขาว
ขาวค่ะเปลี่ยนผู้หญิงล่ะคะถ้าครูหญิงคิด
ผู้หญิงจะอีสัตว์
กูหญิงคิดเป็นอะไรผู้หญิงจะเป็นโลมาถ้า
ค่ะทำไมเป็นโลมา
อยู่ในน้ำ
โรมาเนี่ยอยู่ในน้ำสมัยโรมาอยู่ในน้ำ
อยู่ในน้ำก็ไม่ร้อนเหมือนคนฟ้า
เปลี่ยนหรอคะนักเรียนจะเป็นอะไรถ้าเป็น
สัตว์ได้ 1 ตัวคอมเมนท์ได้นะเล่นกับเรา
ได้นะคะอ่ะข้อที่ 2
ข้อที่ 2 นะคะในโลกใช่ไหมโลกของเราเนี่ย
ก็มีแคนาดาอเมริกาเม็กซิโกบราซิลรัสเซีย
จีนอินเดียแอฟริกาออสเตรเลียนิวซีแลนด์
ไทยสมัยในโลกถ้าครูฟ้านะคะ
โลกนะจะมีบ้าน
หมู่บ้านเนี่ยอยู่ที่ไหนในโลกก็ได้อยู่
ที่ไหนก็ได้ครูฟ้าอยากมีบ้านอยู่ที่ไหนใน
โลก
ประเทศอะไร
ลูกค้าอยากมีบ้าน
อยู่ที่ประเทศ
อะไรดีวิตเซอร์แลนด์ค่ะ of  Switzerland
ใช่ไหมครูฟ้าชอบสวิตเซอร์แลนด์
[เพลง]
ผู้หญิงล่ะคะผู้หญิงอยากมีบ้านอยู่ที่ไหน
อยู่อลาสก้า
อลาสกา
ผู้หญิงจะเป็นเอสกิโมหรอสอบผู้หญิงอยาก
อยู่ที่หนาวๆอ่ะผู้หญิงอยากมีบ้านอลาสกา
ค่ะครูฟ้าอยากอยู่ที่อลาสกันถ้าเขาไม่ชอบ
กินกลายคุยก็มีปลาค่ะนักเรียนล่ะที่
สุดที่ไหนคอมเม้นได้แล้วไหนวะไทยๆๆๆ
ข้อที่ 3 ข้อที่ 3 เนี่ยนะคะพรุ่งนี้ผู้
หญิงไม่มีรูปอ่ะถ้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยกินผักคือ
ครูฟ้าน่ากินหมูกินไก่กินปลาไม่ได้นะคะ
ไม่ได้
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยกินได้แค่ผัด
ผักผักเรียนภาพนี่นี่
คือผัดนะผักไม่มีมะเขือเทศนะคะพริกหวาน
เนาะบล็อคเคอรี่แครอทนะคะผัดถ้าครูฟ้ากิน
ได้แค่ผัดเข้านั้นหมูไก่ปลาแอปเปิล
สตรอเบอร์รี่ไม่ได้อ่ะแล้วก็กินได้ 1
อย่าง
กินผักได้หนึ่งอย่าง
ครูฟ้าคิดว่าจะกินผักอะไร
ดูมาคิดว่า
จะกิน
ผักบุ้งต่ออ๋อ
ค่ะบุ้งขนาดเปลี่ยนมาชอบกินผักบุ้ง
ผักบุ้งนะคะรู้ว่านักเรียนอาจจะเคยเห็น
เอาเอา
คลิปบุ๊คก็เป็นเต่านะคะนี่ค่ะผัดผักบุ้ง
แนวคูฟ้าเลือกกินผักบุ้งสมัยถ้ากินผัดได้
1 อย่างเท่านั้นแล้วก็ต้องกินวันทุกวัน
ทุกวันครูฟ้าคิดผักบุ้งผักบุ้งกับผู้หญิง
แล้วครูหญิงล่ะผู้หญิงจะเลือกผักอะไร
ผู้หญิงคิดว่าท่านผู้หญิงเลือดมะเขือเทศ
แล้วกันเมื่อคืนทำไมอ่ะหน่อยนะกินเข้าไป
กับผมกินง่ายๆไม่ต้องทำและมีมะเขือเทศ
แล้วก็ล้างแล้วก็กินได้เลยนั้นก็เลยคิด
ว่าจะกินมะเขือเทศนะคะนักเรียนล่ะนัก
เรียนจะกินอะไร comment ได้นะคะอ่ะข้อที่
ถ้าครูฟ้าเป็นการ์ตูนเป็นคาแรคเตอร์ใน
การ์ตูนได้ 1 ตัว
อะไรก็ได้นะคะการ์ตูนน้องไม่ว่าจะเป็น
มิกกี้เม้าส์
โดนัลด์ดั๊กหมีพูห์ผู้นารูโตะแล้วมีอะไร
อีกล่ะ
เอลซ่า
สโนว์ไวท์ที่เป็นการ์ตูนนะคะที่เป็น
การ์ตูน
ครูฟ้าจะเป็นการ์ตูนจะเป็นใครถ้าเป็น
การ์ตูนได้มีตัวครูฝาจะเป็นใคร
รูปฟ้า
จะเป็น
หมดเวลา
แป๊บนึงนักเรียนครูฟ้าจะเป็น
โนบิตะ
ผู้หญิงเปิดให้ดูนะคะนี่ค่ะนี่ค่ะโนบิตะ
เนาะโนบิตะเป็นการ์ตูนญี่ปุ่นนะคะอยู่ใน
เรื่อง
โดราเอมอน
นี่นะคะนักเรียนจะมีโดราเอมอนอันนี้แล้ว
ก็โนบิตะ
ทำไมได้อะไรครูฟ้าเป็นโนบิตะ
ก็จะได้มีโดราเอมอนเนี่ยก็อยากนะ
What โดเรมอนมี Power มีเมจิกใช่ไหมไม่
มีเมจิกสิเป็นโรบอทแต่ว่าโดเรม่อนโอ้โห้
ของเยอะของเยอะไหมถ้าครูฟ้าขี้เกียจก็
โดเรมอนมีของมีของ
ว่าอยากมีโดเรมอนค่ะผู้หญิงล่ะคะผู้หญิง
เลือกอะไรจะตูนถ้าเล่นจะตูนหรอเป็น
การ์ตูนได้ 1 ตัวผู้หญิงอยากเป็น
อันนี้ละกัน
อะไรเอ่ยไจแอนท์
ผู้หญิงปล่อยครูฟ้าไงครูฟ้าเป็นโนบิตะผู้
หญิงก็เป็นไจแอนท์อยู่ในเรื่องเดียวกัน
นั้นคุยก็แบบครูฟ้าโนบิตะจะเอาของโดเรมอน
ว่ะสู้กับครูหินนะผู้หญิงก็จะเป็นไจแอนท์
แค่นี้แรง
[เพลง]
ต่อไปเออนักเรียนอยากเป็นอะไร No  comment
ได้นะคะบอกเราได้นะแต่ละ 1 ข้อ 1 ข้อ 2
ข้อ 3 ก็ 4 อ่ะข้อที่ 5 มาหาข้อที่ 5 ถ้า
ครูฟ้า
นะอันนี้ครูฟ้านะคะ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยแต่งงานนะแต่งงานแต่นแต้นจริง
ๆ
แต่นแตนแตนแต่งงานกับใครก็ได้
ใครก็ได้อ่าจะตายแล้วยังไม่ตายเราจะเป็น
ผู้ชายเป็นผู้หญิงเป็นใครก็ได้ 1 คนแต่
ถ้าครูบาอาจารย์แต่งงานกับใครก็ได้ 1 คน
ครูฟ้าจะแต่งงานกับใคร
รูปพระแต่งงานกับใครกูพาคิดแจ็คสเปโร่
ราคาแต่ว่า
เป็นก็มีคาแรคเตอร์
วอดิสนี่มีอยู่จริงแต่ว่าแวะไปงานได้กู
ฟ้าไม่มีอยู่จริงก็ได้เอ่อไม่ได้เนาะต้อง
เป็นคนต้องเป็นคนที่มีจริงๆ
แต่งงานกับ
หนิงแต่งงานกับใครอ่ะไม่เอาคาแรคเตอร์
ด้วยก็ได้เพราะเป็นคนจริงๆหญิงก็กินไม่
ออกอ่ะเอาคาแรคเตอร์ด้วยเอาคาแรคเตอร์ใคร
ก็ได้จะเป็นคนจริงๆจะเป็นคาแรคเตอร์ใน
ละครในซีรีย์ในหนัง
Iron  Man
สีฟ้าจะแต่งกับใครคะเมื่อวานอู๋ฟ้าดู
ซีรีส์เรื่องนึงนะมาแต่งงานกับกรงอยู่ว่า
ได้หา
เรียนรู้จักเขาไหมล่ะเขาเป็นใครคะครูฟ้า
ตรง you พระเอก series  korea ล้วนซีที่
อยู่ขอดูเมื่อวานคงอยู่
หน้าวัดแต่งงานคงอยู่นะคะค่ะ
คืนนะคะผู้หญิงไหมจริง
ผู้หญิงแต่งงานกับใครคะผู้หญิงสระแต่งงาน
กับ
ผู้หญิงก็แต่งงานกับคนแข่งงาน
News
นิ้วนิ้วนิ้ว Times  Under
อาหาร
มันไม่จริง
สมัยสมัยเพราะว่าเนี่ยนักเรียนเขามี
กระเป๋าอ่ะแล้วในกระเป๋าเวลาเปิดก็จะมี
สัตว์ใช่ไหมคะมีสัตว์อะไรก็ไม่รู้ที่มัน
น่ารักนะคะผู้หญิงก็เลยคิดว่าสีจะแต่งงาน
กับเขาอ่ะ
มีอะไรล่ะก็แต่งงานกับใครเนาะอ่าต่อไปข้อ
ที่ 7 แล้วใช่ไหมครูฟ้าให้ข้อที่ 6 ข้อ
ที่ 6 นะคะอ่ะถ้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยวันนี้ครูฟ้า
ใส่เสื้อสีอะไร
สีดำสีดำแต่ถ้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยใส่เสื้อน้ำใส่
เสื้อได้สีเดียวเท่านั้นอ้ะก็คือ
ทุกวันทุกวันทุกวันนะตั้งแต่ตอนนี้จนครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยตายครูฟ้าใส่เสื้อได้สีเดียว
เปลี่ยนเปลี่ยนไม่ได้ครูฟ้าจะใส่เสื้อสี
อะไรคือไม่ใช่แค่เสื้ออย่างเดียวนะเสื้อ
ผ้าด้วยแล้วคือ
เสื้อเสื้อ
กางเกงด้ายสีเดียวเปลี่ยนมีสีไม่ได้ครู
ฟ้าจะใส่เสื้อใส่กางเกงสีอะไรจะเลือกสี
อะไร
สีเหลืองค่ะ
ตอนนี้นี่ผู้หญิงนี่
สีเหลืองนะคะสีเหลืองครูฟ้าทำไมอ่ะก็กู
ชอบสีเหลืองไงคะเวลาเราชอบคณะผู้ฟ้าชอบสี
เหลืองว่าใส่เสื้อสีเหลืองกางเกงสีเหลือง
Red สีเหลืองก็จะแฮปปี้พบชอบสีเหลือง
แล้วก็มาต้องใส่สีเดียวทุกวันจนตายก็ต้อง
เอาสีที่ครูฟ้าชอบว่าชอบสีเหลืองนะคะผู้
หญิงล่ะคะชอบผู้หญิงจะเลือกสีอะไรสีขาว
เนี่ย
สีขาวสีขาวผู้หญิงไม่ได้ชอบสีขาวนะแต่แค่
ผู้หญิงคิดว่าเวลาผู้หญิงใส่เสื้อสีขาว
แล้วรู้สึกโอเคเองสบายใจแบบถ้าคุณใส่สี
เหลืองเสื้อเนี่ยเป็นสีเหลืองสีเหลืองใช่
ไหมเองโอเคไหมโอเคไหมแต่ถ้าเป็นสีขาวผิว
รู้สึกโอเคก็เลยคิดว่าสีขาวเป็นพระเลยนะ
เป็นแม่ชี
อีกหนึ่งอ้ออีก 1 ข้อ
ข้อสุดท้ายนักเรียนล่ะนักเรียนเจ้าใสสี
อะไรนะคะอ่ะอีก 1 ข้อนะคะอันนี้ในตัวครู
ฟ้าใช่ไหมมีผมมีคิ้วมีตาตามีจมูกมีปากมี
ฟันมีหูอาหารชนิดในร่างกายครูฟ้าเนาะถ้า
คือฟ้าจะเปลี่ยน 1 ยางในตัวครูฟ้า
ครูฟ้าจะเปลี่ยนอะไรในตัวครูฟ้าว่าจะ
เปลี่ยนอะไรเปลี่ยน
ร้าน
อาหารเห็นตาทำไมอ่ะเปลี่ยนให้มันเล็กหรือ
ว่ามันโต
เปลี่ยนให้มีตา 2 ฉัน
ม้าของท่านนักเรียนคือตอนนี้อันนี้ตาครู
ฟ้าใช่ไหมคะตาแล้วก็นี้คิ้วราคาคิ้วขึ้น
ฟ้าเนี่ยตาชั้นเดียวไม่โอเคครูฟ้ายาก
เปลี่ยน
นี้ใช้ไฟฟ้าไปฮะตาสองชั้น
ทรายนี่เขาก็มีตาสองชั้นน่ะเห็น
ไปรับลูกค้าลืมตาบอกไม่เห็น
หลายอย่างค่ะผู้หญิงล่ะคะผู้หญิงจะ
เปลี่ยนอะไร
ผู้หญิงอยากเปลี่ยนคิวค่ะคิวทำไมคะผู้
หญิงมี
ถ้าหิวเนี่ยสมัยคิว
มันก็จะมีขนคิ้วเนาะเร็วๆว่าขนคิ้วขนคิ้ว
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยมีขนคิ้วนิดหน่อยนะคะคุณอยาก
มีแบบเหมือนครูฟ้าขนคิ้วขนคิ้วขนคิ้วขน
คิ้วขนคิ้วขนคิ้วขนคิ้วขนคิ้วเยอะๆนะอย่า
เปลี่ยนเป็นแบบนี้ Before  After นะคะพี่
จะได้ไม่ต้องทุกวันเขียนคิ้ว
ง้อ
แล้วนักเรียนเหรอคะนักเรียนอยากเปลี่ยน
อะไรก็คอมเมนต์ไม่ได้เลยนะคะจ่าย
คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้เนาะส่วนวีดีโอนี้เรา
สองคนก็ต้องไปก่อนนะคะแล้วเดี๋ยวเจอกัน
วีดีโอหน้าเนาะสวัสดีค่ะ
น้าน